DOWN UNDER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PAL.
I APPRECIATE IT, MR. PRIME
MINISTER.
I'M HONORED TODAY TO BE JOINED
BY TWO OF AMERICA'S CLOSEST
ALLIES, AUSTRALIA AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM TO LAUNCH A NEW PHASE OF
THE TRILATERAL SECURITY
COOPE
COOPERATION AMONG OUR COUNTRIES.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
PARTNERSHIP, YOUR VISION AS WE
EMBARK TOGETHER ON THIS
STRATEGIC MISSION, ALTHOUGH
AUSTRALIA, THE UK AND U.S.
PARTNERSHIP, AUKUS.
OUR NATIONS WILL UPDATE OUR
SHARED ABILITY TO TAKE ON THE
THREATS OF THE 21st CENTURY,
JUST AS WE DID IN THE 20th
CENTURY TOGETHER.
OUR NATIONS AND OUR BRAVE
FIGHTING FORCES HAVE STOOD
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER FOR
LITERALLY MORE THAN 100 YEARS
THROUGH THE TRENCH-FIGHTING IN
WORLD WAR I, THE ISLAND-HOPPING
IN WORLD WAR II DURING THE
FRIGID WINTERS IN CORE AND THE
SCORCHING HEAT IN THE PERSIAN
GULF.
THEY HAVE LONG BEEN FAITHFUL AND
CAPABLE PARTNERS.
TODAY WE TAKE ANOTHER HISTORIC
STEP TO DEEPEN AND FORMALIZE
COOPERATION AMONG ALL THREE OF
OUR NATIONS.
BECAUSE WE ALL RECOGNIZE THE
IMPERATIVE OF ENSURING PEACE AND
STABILITY IN THE INDO-PACIFIC
OVER THE LONG TERM.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
BOTH THE CURRENT STRATEGIC
ENVIRONMENT IN THE REGION AND
HOW IT MAY EVOLVE.
BECAUSE THE FUTURE OF EACH OF
OUR NATIONS AND INDEED THE WORLD
DEPENDS ON A FREE AND
INDO-PACIFIC.
THIS IS ABOUT INVESTING IN OUR
ALLIANCES AND UPDATING THEM TO
BETTER MEET THE THREATS OF TODAY
AND TOMORROW.
IT'S ABOUT CONNECTING AMERICA'S
EXISTING ALLIES AND PARTNERS IN
NEW WAYS AND AMPLIFYING OUR
ABILITY TO COLLABORATE,
RECOGNIZING THERE IS NO REGIONAL
DIVIDE SEPARATING THE INTEREST
OF OUR ATLANTIC AND PACIFIC
PARTNERS.
INDEED, THIS EFFORT REFLECTS THE
BROADER TREND OF KEY EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES PLAYING AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
INDO-PACIFIC.
FRANCE IN PARTICULAR ALREADY HAS
SUBSTANTIAL INDO-PACIFIC
PRESENCE AND IS A KEY PARTNER
AND ALLY IN STRENGTHENING THE
SECURITY AND PROSPERITY OF THE
REGION.
THE UNITED STATES LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH FRANCE
AND OTHER KEY COUNTRIES AS WE GO
FORWARD.
AND, FINALLY, THIS INITIATIVE IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT EACH OF
US HAS A MODERN CAPABILITY, THE
MOST MODERN CAPABILITIES WE NEED
TO MANEUVER AND DEFEND AGAINST
RAPIDLY EVOLVING THREATS.
AUKUS WILL BRING TOGETHER OUR
SAILORS, OUR SCIENTISTS, AND OUR
INDUSTRIES TO MAINTAIN AND
EXPAND OUR AGING MILITARY
CAPABILITIES AND CRITICAL
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS CYBER,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE, QUANTUM
TECHNOLOGIES AND UNDERSEA
DOMAINS.
NOW AS A KEY PROJECT UNDER
AUKUS, WE ARE LAUNCHING
CONSULTATIONS WITH AUSTRALIA'S
ACQUISITION OF CONVENTIONALLY
ARMED NUCLEAR-POWERED SUBMARINES
FOR ITS NAVY, CONVENTIONALLY
ARMED.
I WANT TO BE EXCEEDINGLY CLEAR
ABOUT THIS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT NUCLEAR
ARMED SUBMARINES.
THESE ARE CONVENTIONAL
SUBMARINES THAT ARE POWERED BY
NUCLEAR REACTORS.
AND THE UNITED STATES AND THE UK
HAVE BEEN OPERATING THESE FOR
DECADES.
I HAVE ASKED SECRETARY AUSTIN OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE TO
LEAD THIS EFFORT OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE.
OUR GOVERNMENTS WILL NOW LAUNCH
AN 18-MONTH CONSULTATION PERIOD
TO DETERMINE EVERY ELEMENT OF
THIS PROGRAM FROM WORKFORCE TO
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS, TO
PRODUCTION TIMELINES, TO
SAFEGUARDS AND NONPROLIFERATION
MEASURES AND TO NUCLEAR
STEWARDSHIP AND SAFETY TO ENSURE
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH EACH OF OUR
NATIONS' COMMITMENTS OF THE
NUCLEAR NONPROLIFERATION TREATY.
THIS REFLECTS THE LONGSTANDING
LEADERSHIP IN GLOBAL
NONPROLIFERATION AND VIGOROUS
VERIFICATION STANDARDS IN
PARTNERSHIP, IN CONSULT WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC ENERGY
AGENCY.
SO I WANT TO THANK THE PRIME
MINISTER, PRIME MINISTER
MORRISON AND PRIME MINISTER
JOHNSON FOR THEIR FRIENDSHIP,
BUT MOSTLY IMPORTANT, FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND PARTNERSHIP AS WE
UNDERTAKE THIS NEW PHASE OF OUR
SECURITY COOPERATION.
AND THE UNITED STATES WILL ALSO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ASEAN AND
THE QUAD AS WAS STATED EARLIER.
OUR FIVE TREATY ALLIES AND OTHER
CLOSE PARTNERS IN THE
INDO-PACIFIC AS WELL AS ALLIES
AND PARTNERS IN EUROPE AND
AROUND THE WORLD TO MAINTAIN A
FREE AND OPEN INDO-PACIFIC AND
BUILD A FUTURE OF PEACE,
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
OF THE REGION.
WE'RE JOINING TOGETHER WHERE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE GETTING
STRONGER.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL, AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING BOTH OF
YOU IN PERSON VERY SOON, I HOPE.
THANK YOU.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, DID YOU TELL
PRESIDENT XI WHEN YOU SPOKE TO
HIM LAST WEEK?
>> YOU HAVE BEEN LISTENING TO A
MAJOR NATIONAL SECURITY
ANNOUNCEMENT PRESIDENT BIDEN
JOINED BY THE LEADERS, THE PRIME
MINISTERS OF THE UNITED KINGDOM
AND AUSTRALIA ANNOUNCING THAT
THE U.S. AND UK WILL HELP
AUSTRALIA ACQUIRE AND DEPLOY
NUCLEAR-POWERED SUBMARINES.
THAT'S DIFFERENT THAN A
NUCLEARLY ARMED SUBMARINE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS STEP ABOUT
COUNTERING THE INCREASING
FLEXING OF MUSCLE BY CHINA IN
THE PACIFIC.
SO LET'S GET YOU UP TO SPEED.
AND, FRANKLY, WE NEED TO TAKE A
MOMENT HERE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE UNITED STATES ON FOREIGN
POLICY HAS, TO A GREAT DEGREE,
BEEN FOCUSED EITHER ON
COUNTERTERRORISM, THE WARS IN
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN AND THE
THREAT FROM RUSSIA.
WE HAVEN'T REALLY IN THE NEWS
MEDIA FOCUSED A GREAT DEAL ON
CHINA.
SO, LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW BIG A
DEAL THIS IS.
THE U.S. IS GOING TO HELP
AUSTRALIA AND THE UK ARE GOING
TO HELP AUSTRALIA GET
NUCLEAR-POWERED SUBMARINES.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN A
NUCLEAR-ARMED SUBMARINE, RIGHT?
>> IT DOES NOT.
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION, WHICH, AS WE NOTE,
THE PRESIDENT TOOK CARE TO MAKE.
IT IS A BIG DEAL NO MATTER HOW
YOU LOOK AT IT ON SEVERAL
LEVELS.
FIRST, IN MY MIND, IT REALLY
BREATHES LIFE INTO THE NOTION OF
A PIVOT TO ASIA, WHICH WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR A LONG
TIME.
>> FOR DECADES.
>> AND IT'S A VERY BOLD STEP FOR
THE AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT AND
THE AUSTRALIAN PEOPLE TO TAKE.
IT CONVEYS --
>> WHY IS IT A BOLD STEP?
>> THE NOTION OF A NUCLEAR
CAPABILITY ARE SOMEWHAT
CONTROVERSIAL.
THEY CERTAINLY WEREN'T IN NEW
ZEALAND, WHICH OF COURSE IS NOT
PART OF THIS.
SO I JUST THINK -- AND THE FACT
THAT GIVEN THE DEPENDENCE THAT
AUSTRALIA HAS ON CHINA FOR ITS
ECONOMY, IT'S A BOLD STEP
BECAUSE CLEARLY THE CHINESE WILL
VIEW THIS AS PROVOCATIVE.
AND THEY SHOULD.
IT ALSO, I THINK, DEMONSTRATES A
REAL PIVOT AWAY FROM THE
DISTRACTIONS THAT YOU MENTIONED,
AFGHANISTAN, COUNTERTERRORISM,
INTO A STRATEGIC RELATIONSHIP
THAT WE'VE ALWAYS HAD A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH AUSTRALIA,
CLEARLY, CERTAINLY I CAN ATTEST
TO THE INTELLIGENCE DOMAIN.
THIS WILL PROFOUNDLY EXTEND THE
CAPABILITY OF AUSTRALIAN NAVY,
AND IN A SENSE EXPAND THE SIZE
OF THE FLEET AVAILABLE TO THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE WE ARE SO
INTEROPERABLE.
SO, IN MY MIND ON SEVERAL LEVELS
A REALLY BIG DEAL, AND
COINCIDENTALLY COMING ON THE
RIGHT TIME TO COINCIDE WITH THE
70th ANNIVERSARY OF THE
AUSTRALIA/NEW ZEALAND/U.S.
TREATY.
IT'S YET ANOTH